welcome to the presentation on adding
and subtracting negative numbers so
let's let's get started so what is a
negative number first of all well let me
draw a number line well it's not much of
a line but I think you'll get the
picture so we're used to the positive
number so if that's 0 you have 1 you
have to a f3 yeah or and you keep going
and if I were to say what's 2 plus 2
you'd start at 2 and then you'd add to
get to 4 I mean most of us second nature
but if you actually drew it on a number
line and say 2 plus 2 is 4 and if I
asked you what's 2 minus 1 or let's say
what's 3 minus 2 if you started at 3 and
you subtract it to you would end up at 1
that's 2 plus 2 is equal to 4 and 3
minus 1 is 3 minus 2 is equal to 1 now
this is a joke for you now what if I
were to say what is 1 minus 3 huh well
it's the same thing you start at 1 and
we're going to go 1 well now we're going
to go below 0 what happens below 0 well
then you start going to the negative
numbers negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
and so on so if I start at 1 right here
so 1 minus 3 so 1 so I go 1 2 3 I end up
at negative 2 so 1 minus 3 is equal to
negative 2 and this is something you're
probably already doing in your everyday
life if I were to if I were to tell you
that voice you're very cold today it's
one degree but tomorrow it's going to be
3 degrees colder you might already know
intuitively well then we're going to be
at the temperature of negative 2 degrees
so that's all a negative number means
and just remember when a negative number
is big so like negative negative 50
that's actually colder than negative 20
right so a negative 50 is actually even
a smaller number than negative 20
because it's even further to the left of
negative 20 that's just something you
you'll get an intuitive feel for
sometimes when you start you feel like
oh 50 is a bigger number than 20 but
it's a negative 50 as opposed to a
positive 50 so so let's let's do some
problems and I'm going to keep using the
number line because I think it's useful
so let's do the problem let's do the
problem 5-12 I think you already might
have an intuition of what this equals
but let me draw a line 5-12 okay whoops
5-12
so let me start with minus 10 minus 9
minus 8 I think I'm gonna run out of
space minus 7 minus 6 minus 5 I should
have this pre-drawn minus 4 minus 3
minus 2 minus 1 0 1 2 3 4 and we'll put
5 right here push this arrow out a
little bit okay 5 minus 12 so if we
start at 5 let me use a different color
we start at 5 right here and we're going
to go to the left 12 so we're
subtracting 12 so then we go 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 negative 7 that's pretty
interesting
because it also happens to be the 12
minus 5 is equal to positive 7 so I want
you to think a little bit about why that
is why why the differently 12 + 5 is 7
and the difference between between well
I guess it's either way in this
situation we're also saying that the
district + 12 is negative 7 but the
numbers are that far apart but now we're
starting with the lower number I think
that last sentence just completely
confused you but we'll keep moving
forward we just had 5 minus 12 is equal
to is equal to minus 7 let's do another
one let's add what if it was negative 3
plus 5
equals what well let's use the same
number line let's go to negative three
plus five so we're going to go to the
right five one two three four five two
and get this to two it equals two so
negative three plus five this equals two
and that's interesting because five
minus three is also equal to two
well it turns out that five minus three
is the same thing it's just another way
of writing five plus negative 3 or
negative three plus five so general easy
way to always do negative numbers is
this just like regular subtraction and
addition and subtraction but now when we
subtract we can go to the left below
zero let's do another one so what
happens when you get let's say 2 minus
minus 3 well if you if you think about
why how it should work out I think this
will make sense but it turns out that
the negative number the negative signs
actually cancel out so this is the same
thing as 2 plus plus 3 and that just
equals 5 another way you could say is
let's do another one what is negative 7
minus minus 2 well that's the same thing
as negative 7 plus 2 and remember so
we're going to start at negative 7 and
we're going to move two to the right so
if we move one to the right we go to
negative 6 and then we move to the right
we get negative 5 and that makes sense
because negative 7 plus 2 that's the
same thing as 2 minus 7 if it's 2
degrees and it gets 7 degrees colder
it's minus 5 let's do a bunch of these I
think the more you do the more practice
you have and the modules explain it
pretty well probably better than I do so
let's just do a ton of problems so if I
said negative 7 minus 3
well now we're going to go three to the
left of negative seven we're going to
get three less than negative seven so
that's negative 10 right that makes
sense because if we had positive seven
plus three worth seven to the right of
zero and we're going to go three more to
the right of zero and we get positive
ten so for seven to the left of zero and
we go three more to the left we're going
to get negative ten let's do a bunch
more I know I'm probably confusing you
but practice is what's going to really
help us so let's say 3 minus minus three
well these negatives cancel out so that
just equals 6 what's 3 minus 3 well take
minus 3 that's easy that's just 0 what's
minus 3 minus 3 well now we're going to
get three less than minus 3
well that's minus 6 what's minus 3 minus
minus 3 interesting
well the minuses cancel out so you get
minus 3 plus 3 well if we start 3 to the
left of 0 and remove 3 3 to the right we
end up at 0 again so that makes sense
right because if we said let me do that
again
minus 3 minus minus 3 anything minus
itself should equal 0 right and that's
why that equals 0 and that's why it
makes sense that those two negatives
cancel out that's the same thing as this
let's do a bunch more
let's do 12 - 13 I think you should be
oh that's pretty easy well we're going
to go all the 12 minus 12 is 0 so 12
minus 13 is negative 1 because we're
going to go 1 to the left of 0 let's do
8 minus 5 well this one is just a normal
ball that's 3 what's 5 minus 8 well
we're going to go all the way to 0 and
then 3 more to the left of 0 so that's
minus 3 I mean I could draw a number
line here if this is 0 this is 5 and now
we're going to go to the left
8
and then we end up at negative three and
you can do that for all of these that's
actually might be good exercise I think
this will give you a good introduction
and I recommend that you just do the
modules because the module is actually
especially if you do the hints it has a
pretty nice graphic that's a lot nicer
than anything I could draw on this
chalkboard so try that out and I'm going
to try to record some more modules that
hopefully won't confuse you as badly and
you could also attend the seminar on
adding and subtracting negative numbers
I hope you have fun bye